Yok ben öyle bir düştüm ki ayaklarımla
altındaki o soğuk toprağa jinamın
ucundan saçımın teline kadar hissettim
ben öyle bir düştüm ki bu hayata hiç
gelmemiş olmayı diledim ben öyle bir
düştüm ki bir an geldi Nefessiz Kaldım
ama aslında gerçek oksijeni o zaman
alıyormuşum anladım bir an geldi tamam
tamam artık şimdi Öldüm de bu hayat
bitti dedim Meğer yeniden yaşamaya
başlamışım ben
de böyle bir düştüm ki yapıştırdığım
yerden Bir Daha kalkamam dedim ama
meğerse ayakta ymış böyle kaderin deyip
tamam mı sürecek kentten gerçek mucize
Aslında Benmişim Anladım hoşgeldiniz Ben
Özge Özge Uzun Aslında bu hayatta birçok
sıfatı beraberinde taşıyorum ama sizi
birinin kızıyım Bir adamın sevgilisiyim
Bazen beni ekranda izleyenler için bir
hayalim başka bir kadının rakibi yim yim
iki çocuğun annesiyim birçok sıfatım var
bu yaşamda ama sadece Özgeciğim adımla
Özdeş yabancı başka benzersiz sadece
patlarım tanımlamaları mı oldukça fazla
ama sadece bir kadın olmayı
da çoğunlukla tercih ediyorum ben neden
buradayım aç Çünkü Allah için çok iyi
düşünüyorum ve size Bunun nasıl
gerçekleştiğini düşmenin ne kadar güzel
bir şey olduğunu çünkü takmanın değerini
bilmeyi bize gösterdiğini anlatmak için
buradayım Ve tabii ki düştüğümü
söylemekten bunu göstermekten kol
kırılır yen içinde kalır demediğim için
de bu cesarete sahip olduğum için
karşınızdayım çok şanslıyım Çünkü hayat
Baya uzun zaman beni denedim insan
düştüğünü hemen anlayamıyor bölümü minik
minik seni dinlemeye başlıyorsun Hatta
sanki ayaktayım zannediyorsun Ama öyle
olmuyor bir tane uçak düşünün irtifa
kaybediyor böyle yürüyor gidiyor uçuyor
diyorsun ki ah yükseklerdeyim işte her
şey harika Aslında göstergeler bozulmuş
daha doğru çakılmayan
ne olacak işte benim hayatımda Aynen
öyleydi 18 yaşındaydım Ben evden
kaçtığımda Yanlış duymadınız Evden
kaçtım ben Ankara'da ve Binbir hayale
İstanbul'a geldim bir aşkın peşinden ter
zaman olduğu gibi ve onunla beraberdi
hayatım bambaşka bir hala almaya başladı
Kendimi Bildim Bileli hep çok çalıştım
birçok hayalim vardı aslında köklenmek
de benim hayalim ama maalesef belki
boşalmış bir anne-babanın çocuğu
olmamdan kaynaklı belki yaşadığım başka
durumlardan kaynaklı her zaman aidiyet
duygusuyla ilgili bir sıkıntım vardı
kökler edemiyordum güvenli
Bağlanamıyorum ve bu yüzden de genelde
hep aşkı tutunmaya çalışıyordu aşk aşk
bildiklerim benim hayatımı en
yönlendiren olgular oldu şimdiye kadar
barc
O yüzden takdir ettiğim en büyük
huylarından bir tanesi çok çalışkan
olmam kendi içinde bulunduğum ve
bildiğim eksiklikleri Aslında çalışarak
tamamladım ve o eksiklikleri göstermeden
işim de hep çok başarılı oldum iş ve
işte elde ettiği başarı sanki içimdeki
duygusal Boşluğu da kapatıyor Muş gibi
zannettim ama çok yanılmışım 28 yaşında
genç bir kadın Getirin gözünüzün önüne
bariyerinde oldukça başarılı p sevdiği
adam yanıt artık evlenmenin vakti gelmiş
ve bununla beraber de çoğalmanın vakti
gelmiş işte diyor kadın şimdiye kadar
yaşadığım her şey bitmiş bir şimdiye
kadar yaşadığım her şeyin ödüllü bir
bebekle beraber olacağım 17 Kasım 2007
sabah saat 8.30
ve bu genç kadın büyük bir heyecanla
hastaneye gidiyor ilk bebeğini kucağına
alabilmek için ameliyathaneye giriyor E
yanında işi Doktorlar çok heyecanlı
mısın Doktor yüzünü okşamaya başlıyor
diyor ki Özge işte geliyor bebeğin Hazır
mısın sıno anda içinden yepyeni bir
canlının çıktığını görüyor ama hiçbir
şey göremiyor Çünkü siyah bir şey
çıkıyor Çünkü oradan Şimdiye kadar
izlediğim bütün doğum videolarında
filmlerde Aslında Bebek anneden
çıktığında pembe beyaz olur ve bir anda
doktorun p******* attığı bir şaplakla
ağlamaya başlar ama onu da tam tersi
oluyor pembe beyaz yerine simsiyah bir
bebek çıkıyor
Ben de hiç ağlamıyor o panikle beraber
Doktorlar işte bebeği alıyorlar Özge
soruyor diyor ki Ne oldu bebeğim iyi mi
Bir sıkıntı mı var bana söylemediniz bir
şey mi var bu Tabii ki çok bir şey
anlatmıyor lar bir erkek çocuğu Dünyaya
Geliyor birden çok aykırılıkları doğuyor
bu dünyaya fiziksel olarak yaşadığı iç
organlarını kapladığı birden çok
aykırılık layani bizim söylememiz ile
engelli bir çocuk oluyor Özge Aslında
yaptığı işle beraber sanki toplumun
içini çok daha iyi biliyormuş gibi
düşünen Özge ilk defa böyle bir şeyle
karşılaşıyor ve o anda yer yarılsa da
içine girsem ve bir daha hiç çıkmasam
diye düşünüyor
bu Eğer ki ölüm varsa ya da o anda yok
olma isteği varsa işte Tam da o anda
istediği şey Bu yok olmak ve bir daha
gelmemiş olmak bu dünyaya da ama ona
öğretilmiş sorumluluk almak öğretilmiş O
da bu sorumlulukla beraber kalkıyor
video ki ben kendi ellerimle bu çocuğu
tutacağım inat edeceğim ve ayağı tut
kaldıracağım o ayakta kalacak Hayaller
kuruyor çocuğuyla beraber ama anlamıyor
ki aslında yaşadığı o şey yağlamak isyan
etmemek bağırmamak birilerine sığmamak
birilerinden yardım istememek onu daha
da düşürecek başarılı oluyor size
söyleyeyim yedi büyük ameliyatla beraber
Uçucu yine de ayağa kaldırıyor beş buçuk
yaşında da olsa yürütme
bu başlıyor yavaş yavaş kelimeler
söyletmeye başlıyor insanlara çocuğu ile
ilgili konuşmaya başlıyor ilham oluyor
Herkes diyor ki ne kadar güçlü kadın ne
kadar güçlü ne güzel anlatıyor işte Tam
da beni anlatıyor yetmiyor işte bir de
kitap yazıyor soruyor Sizin hiç maviniz
var mı diye anneler mesajlar yazıyorlar
işte Tam beni anlatmışsın benim çocuğum
sağlıklı ama beni okuyunca daha da çok
şükretmeye başladım bunu sanki tekrar
ayağa kaldırıyor olmuş gibi görünüyor
Ama evin içinde yaşadığı şey çok başka
Özge bunların hiçbirini göstermiyor
çünkü evin içinde o dünya güzeli çocuk
başa çıkamadığı duygularla yaşarken hem
kendine hem annesine hem çevresine
fiziksel olarak
o sal olarak maalesef zararlar vermeye
başlıyor ve o anne Özge her gün ekrana
çıkan televizyonda gülümseyen Hatta ve
hatta uzun süre Türkiye gündemini
bacaklarıyla meşgul eden Özge bir
tarafta bunlarla uğraşırken diğer
tarafta evine geliyor ve akşamları
çocuğunu sakinleştirmeye çalışıyor ve
her geçen gün daha da dibe battığın
farkına varmıyor yıl 2013 Temmuz
karnında oluşan yepyeni bir canlı var ve
Dünyaya Geliyor sağlıklı adı siwa bir
kız çocuğu o kız çocuğuyla beraber
umutlarının daha da yükselecek düşünüyor
ki gerçekten öyle oluyor aslında bir
kahramanla uğraştığını bir mucizeye
hayat verdiğini çok daha sonra anlıyor
Özge gerçek mi
ve sıradanlık olduğunu belki gerçek
mucizenin Beş parmağın olmasını gerçek
mucizenin gören Gözde anlayan dilde
duyan kulakta olmasını ve seven
kalplerde Gözde olmasın anlıyorum ama
bir taraftan oğluyla ilgili düşmeleri
devam ediyor ve saldırılara da maruz
kalıyor diyorlar ki ona sen çocuğunu
kullanıyorsun sen yaptığın iş ile
beraber çocuğunu anlatıp bunun üzerinden
reyting elde ediyorsun bunun üzerinden
rant elde ediyorsun sonra düşünmeye
başlıyor diyor ki bu nasıl bir insan
çocuğunu kullanabilir ve onun üzerinden
çıkar sağlayabilir acaba yine de kol
kırılır yen içinde kalır diye düşünüp o
an yaşadığı hiçbir şeyi kimseye
göstermiyor şort ta ki bugüne kadar
o karşımızda gördüğünüz Özge sabah
yayından çıktı bu makyajını yaptın
saçları çok güzel ayakta topuklu
ayakkabılarını giydi gülümsüyor insanlar
sosyal medyadan ona özgür dolu şeyler
yazıyor ama sizi Özge ile daha
tanıştırmak istiyorum o Özge K Bundan
tam bir yıl önce Bakü'de bambaşka bir
ülkede tek başına ama işinden gücünden
ailesinden ayrılmış ve her şeyden kopup
orada yaşamaya başlamış olan kadın bir
gece yine oğlunun çığlıklarıyla uyanıyor
onu sakinleştirmeye çalışıyor Bu Tabii
ki oldu çok güçlü onun hiçbir suçu yok
hiçbir günahı yok çünkü başka türlü
o derdini anlatamıyor ellerini tutuyor
ayaklarını tutuyor ve sonra Özge
vazgeçiyor şu diyor ki bana ne istersen
yapabilirsin Bana istediğin gibi
davranabilirsin yaz suresi ne
göstereceğim kadında aynı şu an sahnede
Duran bu boyalı yüzüyle gülümsemesiyle
belki enerjisinin farklılığıyla
gördüğünüz kadın oradaki kadın da ben o
iki kadını da çok seviyorum Bunu da çok
seviyorum birazdan göreceğiniz kadında
çok seviyorum bugün Buraya gelmenin en
büyük nedenlerinden bir tanesi boyut bu
hayatta birden çok düşebiliriz aşkla
işle arkadaşlarımızla bazen ailemizin
bize yaptıklarıyla burada önemli olan
düşünmek değil aslında nasıl ayağa
kalkabildim siniz
bu ve bir kere düşük ayağa kalkıyorsanız
Eğer inanın Ondan sonra canınız daha az
acımaya başlıyor Hatta düşmeye karşı da
birazcık Ne yapıyorsunuz ve nasıl
düşeceğiniz öğreniyorsunuz gelin Bundan
tam bir yıl önce 22 Şubat 2018 gecesi
gece saat 3'te olduğunu sakinleştir
dikten sonra Konuşacak hiç kimse
bulamayan çevresi çok kalabalık gibi
görünen bir kadının cep telefonunu önüne
alıp kamerada kendisiyle dertleşme
görüntüsünü izleyelim
abone ol
ve bu Özge'yi çok seviyorum kimsenin
acımasına kimsenin yüreğinin vurulmasına
ihtiyacı yok Ne o Özge'nin neden Oo Özge
gibi yaşayan kadınların ve o çocukların
Ama bizim de bazen düşmeye düştükten
sonra yerde kalmaya bazen Hoca'yı sonuna
kadar yaşamaya hakkımız var Ben gün
geldi öyle bir düştüm ki o soğuk toprağa
ayaklarımın altında tırnağımın ucundan
saçımın teline kadar hissettim ben öyle
bir düştüm ki bu hayatı hiç gelmemiş
olmayı diledim ben öyle bir düştüm ki
yani Nefessiz Kaldım zannettim ama
aldığım Eğer gerçek oksijenlenmiş
anladım ben öyle bir düştüm
Evet tamam Hayır bu kaderin için hediye
söyleyecekken gerçek mucize Benmişim ve
gerçek mucize sizmişsiniz bunu anladım
çok teşekkür ederim
abone ol